advice from steve jobs on finding your  passion  as seen in zugu101 the only way to do  great work is to love what you do  if you haven't found it yet keep looking  don't  settle the feelings and the passion that  people put into apple macintosh were  completely  indistinguishable from a poet or painter  people put a lot of love into these  products i was worth over a million  dollars when i was 23 and over 10  million dollars when i was 24  and over 100 million dollars when i was  25 and it wasn't that important because  i never did it for the money  being the richest man in the cemetery  doesn't matter to me  going to bed at night saying we've done  something wonderful  that's what matters to me the only way  to do great work is to love what you do  as with all matters of the heart you'll  know when you find it  to see more check out zuga 101 find your  passion in the link below